good morning the people of Scotland have
spoken and it is a clear result they
have kept our country of four nations
together and like millions of other
people I am delighted as I said during
the campaign it would have broken my
heart to see our united kingdom come to
an end and I know that that sentiment
was shared by people not just across our
country but also around the world
because of what we've achieved together
in the past and what we can do together
in the future so now it is time for our
united kingdom to come together and to
move forward a vital part of that will
be a balanced at settlement fair to
people in Scotland and importantly to
everyone in England Wales and Northern
Ireland as well let us remember first
why we had this debate and why it was
right to do so the Scottish National
Party was elected in Scotland in 2011
and promised a referendum on
independence we could have tried to
block that we could have tried to put it
off but just as with other big issues it
is right to take and not to duck the big
decision I am a passionate believer in
our United Kingdom and I wanted more
than anything for our United Kingdom to
stay together but I am also a Democrat
and it was right that we respected the
SNP's majority in Holyrood and gave the
Scottish people their right to have
their say let us also remember why it
was right to ask the definitive question
yes or no because now the debate has
been settled for a generation or as an
examiner said perhaps for a lifetime so
there can be no disputes no reruns we
have heard the settled will of the
Scottish people Scotland voted for a
stronger Scottish Parliament backed by
the strength and security of the United
Kingdom and I want to congratulate the
no camp
for that for showing people that our
nation's really are better together i
also want to pay tribute to yes scotland
for a well-fought campaign and to say to
all those who did vote for independence
we hear you we now have a chance a great
opportunity to change the way the
british people are governed and change
it for the better political leaders on
all sides of the debate now bear a heavy
responsibility to come together and work
constructively to advance the interests
of people in Scotland as well as those
in England Wales and Northern Ireland
for each and every citizen of our United
Kingdom to those in Scotland skeptical
of the constitutional promises that were
made let me say this we have delivered
on devolution under this government and
we will do so again in the next
parliament the three pro-union parties
have made commitments clear commitments
on further powers for the Scottish
Parliament we will ensure that those
commitments are honored in full and i
can announce today that lord smith of
kelvin who so successfully led Glasgow's
commonwealth games has agreed to oversee
the process to take forward these
devolution commitments with powers over
tax spending and Welfare all agreed by
November and draft legislation published
by January just as the people of
Scotland will have more power over their
affairs so it follows that the people of
England Wales and Northern Ireland must
have a bigger say over there's the
rights of these voters need to be
respected preserved and enhanced it is
absolutely right that a new and fair
settlement for Scotland should be
accompanied by a new and fair settlement
that applies to all parts of our United
Kingdom in Wales there are proposals to
give the Welsh government and assembly
more powers and I want Wales to be at
the heart of the debate on how to make
our United Kingdom work for all our
nation's in Northern Ireland we must
work to ensure that the devolved
institutions
function effectively but I have long
believed that a crucial part missing
from this national discussion is England
we have heard the voice of Scotland and
now the millions of voices of England
must also be heard the question of
English votes for English laws the
so-called West Lothian question requires
a decisive answer so just as Scotland
will vote separately in the Scottish
Parliament on their issues of tax
spending and welfare so to England as
well as Wales and Northern Ireland
should be able to vote on these issues
and all this must take place in tandem
with and at the same pace as the
settlement for Scotland I hope that this
is going to take place on a cross-party
basis I've asked William Hague to draw
up these plans we will set up a Cabinet
Committee right away and proposals will
also be ready to the same timetable I
hope the Labour Party and other parties
will contribute it is also important
that we have wider civic engagement
about how to improve governance
throughout our United Kingdom including
how to empower our great cities and we
will say more about this in the coming
days this referendum has been hard
fought it has stirred strong passions it
has electrified politics in Scotland and
caught the imagination of people across
the whole of our United Kingdom it will
be remembered as a powerful
demonstration of the strength and
vitality of our ancient democracy record
numbers registered to vote and record
numbers cast their vote we should all be
proud of that it has reminded us how
fortunate we are that we are able to
settle these vital issues at the ballot
box peacefully and calmly now we must
look forward and turn this into the
moment when everyone which ever way they
voted comes together to build that
better brighter future for our in tower
entire United Kingdom thank you very
much and good morning